TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi,
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Understanding the
various meanings
of a particular word in text is
key to understanding language.
To help with this
challenge, we're
happy to announce the release
of Word-Sense annotations,
manually annotated with senses
from the new Oxford American
Dictionary.
This is one of the
largest releases
of fully sense-annotated
English corpora,
and the GitHub link
is on the post.
There were three posts
this week from Google Play
in conversation with
developers about their success
on the platform.
First, the co-founder and CEO
and the growth-hacking manager
of Wallapop explained how using
store listening experiments
has increased their
conversion rate by 17%
and has allowed them to
optimize organic installs.
Next are some tips from
Peak and SoundCloud
on how to grow your
startup in Google Play.
And a Southeast
Asian Indie developer
talked about how they
used Google Play features
to improve their conversion
rate by 25%, another
to significantly improve user
retention, and a third to grow
revenue by 100%.
Google Cloud Audit
Logging helps you
determine who did what,
where, and when on Google
Cloud Platform.
We've significantly
expanded the set
of products integrated
including Google Computer Engine
and Google Container Engine.
Details on how to get
started are on the post.
A range of New York
City public datasets
are now available
on Google BigQuery,
including over 8
million 311 service
requests, one billion
yellow and green taxi
rides, and a lot more.
I know this because
Reto Meier told me
so on the first
episode of "Today
I learned with BigQuery."
Follow the link to the
post to see his video
on this newly available
big data or the next link
for this week's episode on how
to run a terabyte of queries
on Google BigQuery each month
without needing a credit card.
One more thing.
We recently announced that
we've signed an agreement
to acquire Fabric to continue
the great work that Twitter
put into the platform.
Fabric will join Google's
developer product group,
working with the Firebase team
to help you build better apps
and grow your business.
Don't forget to
subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks for
watching this week's episode
of the Developer Show.
To catch some of our previous
episodes, check out these links
right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]